nos dicen una muestra de un compuesto
que contiene solo átomos de carbono e
hidrógeno se quema completamente lo que
produce 5.65 gramos de co2 y 3.47 gramos
de h2o cuál es la fórmula empírica del
compuesto pausa el vídeo e inténtalo por
tu cuenta
muy bien vamos a asegurarnos de que
entendemos lo que sucede nos dicen que
tenemos una muestra de un compuesto
misterioso que solo contiene carbono e
hidrógeno es decir cada molécula de este
compuesto misterioso tiene un cierto
número de átomos de carbono
llamémosle equis y un cierto número de
átomos de hidrógeno
llamémosle y lo pondremos en presencia
de oxígeno molecular al aplicarle calor
producirá una combustión y después de
quemarse terminaremos con algo de
dióxido de carbono y con algo de agua lo
que acabamos de escribir es decir esta
reacción química que estamos
describiendo no está balanceada podremos
intentarlo incluso con las xy yesa pero
no es el objetivo de este vídeo en este
vídeo nos dicen cuántos gramos de
dióxido de carbono y de agua obtuvimos
después de la combustión nos lo dicen
justo aquí
entonces lo que necesitamos encontrar
con base en esto es cuántos moles de
dióxido de carbono y cuántos moles de
agua tenemos y con eso encontraremos con
cuántos moles de carbono y de hidrógeno
empezamos por último al ver esta
relación podremos obtener la fórmula
empírica de este compuesto así que para
empezar ya que hablaremos de moles masas
molares y la masa de un mol de una
molécula o átomo vamos a obtener la masa
atómica promedio del carbono del
hidrógeno y del oxígeno para ello vamos
a traer nuestra útil tabla periódica
podemos ver que el hidrógeno tiene una
masa atómica promedio de 1.008 vamos a
escribirlo tenemos que la masa atómica
promedio del hidrógeno es de 1.008
y después tenemos que la masa atómica
promedio del carbono es de 12.01
anotemos lo 12.01 además claro podemos
pensarlo en términos de masas molares
podemos decir que esto equivale a gramos
por mol gramos por mol y por último pero
no por eso menos importante tenemos al
oxígeno el oxígeno tiene 16.00 gramos
por mol esa es su masa atómica promedio
pero también podemos pensarlo como su
masa molar este número es su masa molar
ahora con esta información podremos
encontrar cuántos moles de carbono
tenemos en el producto bueno podemos ver
que todo el carbono del producto está en
el dióxido de carbono entonces tenemos
5.65 gramos de co2 y podemos pensar en
cuántos moles de co2 tenemos aquí así
que vamos a multiplicarlo por un molde
co2
por cada cuántos gramos de co2 bueno
podemos escribirlo por aquí co2 vamos a
tener un carbono y dos oxígenos entonces
sera 12.01 más dos veces 16 gramos por
mol así que veamos 32 2 por 16 32 +
12.01 es 44.0 1 gramos formol pero como
estamos tomando el inverso son moles por
gramo entonces uno entre 44.011 moles
por gramo si sólo hiciéramos esta
operación los gramos de co2 se
cancelarán con los gramos de co2 y esto
nos dará los moles de co2 pero recuerda
que nos interesan los moles de carbono
en el producto
así que multiplicaremos por cuántos
moles de carbono hay por cada molde co2
bueno sabemos que tenemos un molde
carbono por cada molde co2 ya que cada
molécula de co2 tiene sólo un carbono en
ella así que cuánto nos dará esto bueno
tenemos 5.65 / 44.0 uno por uno así que
no necesitamos hacer más esto es
si tomamos tres cifras significativas y
redondeamos nos quedarán 0.121 entonces
es aproximadamente cero punto 128 y
nuestras unidades son moles ya que los
gramos de co2 se cancelan con los gramos
de co2 los moles de co2 se cancelan con
los moles de co2
entonces nos quedan moles de carbono que
es justo lo que queríamos y podemos
hacer el análisis dimensional porque
esto también es intuitivo si estos son
los gramos de co2 que tenemos y un molde
co2 tiene una masa de 44 puntos 0 1
gramos
entonces 5.65 entre esto nos dice que
fracción de mol de co2 tenemos después
cualquier número de moles de dióxido de
carbono que tengamos será exactamente el
mismo que los moles de carbono porque
tenemos un átomo de carbono por cada
molécula de dióxido de carbono
esto tiene sentido bien hagamos lo mismo
para el hidrógeno pensemos en los moles
del hidrógeno en el producto y será el
mismo procedimiento así que si te
sientes inspirado y no pudiste
calcularlo al principio pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo tú solo muy bien todo el
hidrógeno está en el agua sabemos que
tenemos en nuestro producto 3.47 gramos
de agua de h2o y ahora vamos a pensar en
cuántos moles de h2o equivalen esos
gramos
veamos por cada molde agua cuántos
gramos de masa de h2o tenemos bueno
podemos calcularlo acá arriba en una
molécula de h2o tenemos dos hidrógenos
que pesan cada uno 1.008 entonces dos
por 1.008 más la masa atómica promedio
del oxígeno entonces más
6 ok y podemos verlo como la masa en
gramos que tenemos en un molde por lo
tanto esto está dado en gramos por mol y
tenemos 2 x 1.008 es 2.0 16 que es esta
parte de aquí 2.0 16 + 16 es 18.0 16 y
si solo calculamos esto recuerda
obtendríamos la cantidad de moles de
agua que tenemos en el producto pero nos
interesan los moles de hidrógeno
entonces cuántos moles de hidrógeno
tenemos en cada molde agua bueno tenemos
dos moles de hidrógeno por cada molde
agua porque en la molécula de agua
tenemos dos átomos de hidrógeno así que
esto se cancelará con esto y nos
quedaremos con el número de moles de
hidrógeno que buscamos
así que esto será aproximadamente igual
tenemos 3.47 gramos de agua dividido
entre 18.0 16 gramos por mol de agua y
esto nos da el número de moldes de agua
que tenemos y para finalizar por cada
molécula de agua tenemos dos hidrógenos
así que multiplicaremos por dos bueno si
redondeamos a tres cifras significativas
esto será aproximadamente igual a cero
punto 385 0.389 de hidrógeno
bien ahora ya sabemos el número de
átomos de hidrógeno y de carbono así que
para encontrar la fórmula empírica de
este compuesto podemos pensar en la
razón entre estas dos cantidades es
decir vamos a buscar la relación entre
los hidrógenos y los carbonos y esto
será aproximadamente igual a cero punto
385 moles de hidrógeno entre 0 puntos
128 moles de carbono y esto es
aproximadamente igual a amd bueno parece
que es aproximadamente 3 pero vamos a
verificar lo tengo al hidrógeno y lo
divido entre 0 puntos 128 ok si muy muy
cercanos al 3 así que esto es
aproximadamente 3 entonces podemos decir
con bastante confianza que si esto es
cercano al 3 significa que por cada
carbono tenemos 3 hidrógenos en el
compuesto original
por lo tanto la fórmula empírica de mi
compuesto original es ch3 por cada
carbono tenemos 3 hidrógenos ch3 y hemos
acabado